-You have multiple jobs.
-Yes.
-And yet you took
on executive producing
this Snoop Dogg
"Joker´s Wild" show.
How has Snoop been
as a collaborator?
-He´s been great.
He´s been great.
You know what?
He watched this show with
his grandmother as a kid.
And he came on
"The $100,000 Pyramid,"
and we left, and then he said,
"I want to do a show."
And I´m thinking,
"Okay, the guy´s been
hanging out with himself
too long, you know?"
But he brought up
"Joker´s Wild."
Checked it out.
And he´s perfect.
He loves it. He´s into it.
He has a lot of fun.
And that´s really what
hosting a game show´s about,
so I think
it´s a perfect fit for him.
-I will say this,
because I´ve seen him
work with Martha Stewart.
-Yeah, love that.
-You know, he is somebody
who only does stuff he loves.
I don´t think he would
waste time on anything else.
You´re very similar.
You do "Good Morning America"
here in New York.
But you also do
the Fox Sunday show.
So you were in L.A. on Sunday,
and then you take a red eye
every Sunday night
and come here to go to work?
-Yes.
-You love working?
-I´m insane.
-Yeah.
You know, honestly,
I do love working.
I love --
Every job I have is great.
And I think because of
playing football for 15 years,
like, everything now is gravy.
-Yeah.
-And, like, when people go,
"Oh, it´s so hard,"
I´m thinking,
"Nah, it´s not so hard."
-Because I have looked
at all of your jobs.
In none of them
is it legal to hit you.
-Yeah. Exactly.
And then I´m not blamed
when the team loses.
-Yeah.
-I´m not sore the next day.
This is great.
-Yeah. That´s true.
If you guys have a bad episode
of "Good Morning America,"
you don´t walk off and have
somebody be like, "You suck!"
-[ Laughs ]
-Yeah.
-Well, yeah,
that actually has happened.
[ Laughter ]
-But it´s about the football
stuff. It´s not a bad act.
They´re like, "You didn´t throw
to local weather!"
-Exactly. But people
never forget the football.
I think a lot of women know me
from, like, daytime TV
and all that.
They don´t know
I played football.
But for the guy, though --
When I was coming here,
I walk out of my house,
and a guy goes,
"What´s up with your Giants?"
I said, "Dude,
I haven´t played in ten years.
I don´t know. Like..."
-Yeah, right.
-"Forget it, dude.
I have no control."
-Yeah, it´s not like there´s a
board of, like, retired players.
-Exactly. We got to go to
the board of retired players
and say,
"What´s wrong with the team?"
We want them to win
just like everybody else does.
-I want to ask you
about football.
Obviously it´s been
a fraught couple of weeks
with the non-football side
of watching the games.
You come from a military family.
-Yeah.
-Your father was a major
in the Army. Is that correct?
-My dad is a retired major
in the Army, yeah.
-So, how do you feel
about the president sort of --
basically dividing this issue
and saying to take a knee
is this sort of
act of anti-patriotism?
-Well, I think that everybody
has the right to protest.
That´s what
this country´s about.
You have rights here,
plain and simple, first of all.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And I think
equating taking a knee
with patriotism
and being against soldiers
and being against the flag --
I think that the true meaning
of what it was
was about racial inequality.
It was a
totally different issue.
And I see it now
as a distraction away
from other issues that
are going on in the world,
from, you know -- you got North
Korea, you got Puerto Rico.
You have so many other things
going on
that you take the time to pick
on football or basketball?
I just think priorities
need to get in order
in order to do what we need to
do to make the country better.
-You know,
it does strike me that,
you know,
if you´re a fan in the stands,
some fans have obviously
made the choice to boo
when players take a knee.
It seems, though,
within the locker room,
teams have had to address
something that is --
Again, it´s
non-football related.
It strikes me
that you have to --
Ideally, you´d put
all your energy towards
thinking about football
and thinking about the game.
It also strikes me that, you
know, in a football locker room,
you have a lot of white guys,
you have a lot of black guys.
Do you think that they´ve
discussed it in a way
that´s actually been
unifying for them
or given each other
a better understanding
of their positions?
-Absolutely.
And when I was playing,
we had one white
defensive lineman --
Dave Tollefson.
He sent all of us -- We´re on
a group text 10 years later.
He sends us a group text,
and he said,
"I just want you guys to know
that I am with you,
that my kids will understand
that, you know,
everybody´s the same.
You treat the person
for who they are,
not by the color of their skin."
And it meant a lot for us
for him to send us that.
He didn´t have to.
But I think in a locker room,
when you´re going through so
much stuff outside of football,
that´s the one place you go
where everybody has such
an incredible understanding.
It´s a team. I need you,
you need me to be successful.
I don´t care where you´re from
or what you do or who your --
religion, your race, anything.
We´re all here
for one common goal.
And the locker room
is a good safe place for guys,
and I think that´s why you saw
so many guys come together,
so many teams come together
to support each other
because it is --
it´s a special place.
And it´s very hard
to put it into words
when you haven´t been there.
But players support each other
when the times are tough.
And Colin Kaepernick
doesn´t have a job now.
Everybody thinks
he should have a job,
but that´s up to the owners.
But one thing I will say
is that it takes a lot
for a guy
who´s making a lot of money,
which is what everybody
seems to judge somebody by,
to put it on the line
for people who he does not know,
who he owes nothing to.
But for him to say,
"Something´s not right
and I´m going to do
something about it."
And to do something
where at the end of the day,
people will remember him
for that more than sports,
which is the most important
thing in the world.
-Yeah, I do think --
I think you´re so right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And I think, you know --
We talk a lot about courage
in this country and risk.
And what you said is so true.
What´s getting lost in this
is Colin Kaepernick genuinely
did put a lot on the line.
He risked a lot.